[Music]
the race for the white house hinges
on nevada and a handful of other states
here is a look at where we stand now you
see that close
separation the vote count between joe
biden and president trump in several
uncalled states continues to narrow it
all comes down to the numbers at this
point
and we're looking at the electoral
college total right now
253 for joe biden 214
for president trump and of course nevada
all the eyes of the nation
centered on nevada and those six
electoral votes as well as pennsylvania
north carolina georgia and arizona
kirsten
mentioned brian they certainly are all
eyes on our state now president trump
and former vp joe biden separated
by just several thousand here and the
ballot counting continues we have live
team coverage we have kate houston
standing by in our newsroom
but first joe moeller joins us live at
the election center in north las vegas
joe
kirsten people all over the country were
hoping to get some answers today from
nevada but the race still too close to
call tonight
51 thousand votes were to be counted
here at the election center today we'll
get an update on that tomorrow in a
press conference
similar to what we had today according
to the secretary of state 190
000 remain to be counted here in nevada
in clark county there are 63 thousand
votes pending but
only a 12 000 difference so it is a
tight race
mail ballots continue to be coming
continue to come in as well
today the registrar of voters for clark
county said he doesn't expect to get the
bulk
of mail ballots until this weekend it is
possible to know how many ballots
are still out there because everyone was
settled
our goal here in clark county is not to
count fast
we want to make sure that we're being
accurate the results in the state of
nevada obviously are going to be very
important to the entire country and that
is our number one goal
all right a handful of voters who need
to have their id verified have been
contacted and have to do so by tomorrow
at 5 p.m
mail ballots will continue to be counted
through november 12. they simply had to
be postmarked by the third to count
it is possible we won't know if the
states will go blue or red for a few
days now
earlier when this press conference was
happening here at the election center
there was some demonstrators outside and
throughout the day they have lingered
and still there's a handful out here but
there is a protest
planned for this location later on this
evening at six reporting live in north
las vegas jim mullen 8 news